here's some good news Business Insider
with an encouraging report
um
says it took just one semester for
Rochelle srivastava to realize that
college was not what he had hoped quote
as a kid you always imagine college
would be a life-changing experience and
that your freshman year is where you'll
get a chance to discover yourself he
said instead he was forced to take
classes online in the wake of coven and
faced a campus Social Scene that
remained fractured the computer science
major wound up dropping out of UC
Berkeley in Fall 2021 only a few months
after he had enrolled soon after he
decided to launch a startup designed to
help job Seekers find work today as most
of his peers are starting their senior
year of college he's got more than a
million dollars in Venture Capital
funding most of my friends are just now
finally getting adjusted some better
than others the world is rapidly
evolving and so is the college
experience he said servastava is one of
the soaring number of genzirs who has
decided to skip College altogether 4
million fewer teenagers enrolled at a
college in 2022 than in 2012. for many
the price tag has simply grown too
exorbitant to justify the cause from
2010 to 2022 College tuition Rose an
average of 12 percent a year
a year
while overall inflation only increased
an average of 2.6 percent each year
called Swisher Rose an average of 12 a
year I've actually find that shocking I
I mean
of course of course we know the college
tuition is is ridiculously expensive and
only getting more expensive as time goes
on but 12 a year is like astronomical I
mean that's mind-boggling today it costs
at least 104 000 on average to attend
four years of public university and uh
more than 223 000 for a private
university at the same time the salary
students can expect to earn after
graduation haven't kept up with the cost
of college the 2019 report from the fuel
Research Center found that earnings for
young college-educated workers had
remained mostly flat over the past 50
years
four years after graduating according to
recent data from the higher education
Authority a third of students earned
less than forty thousand dollars a year
lower than the average salary of forty
four thousand dollars that workers with
only a high school diploma earn
so you're spending more and more and
more
uh every single year on a college
education and getting less and less for
it is basically the way that the trends
are working the widening gap between the
value and the cost of college has
started to shift gen Z's attitudes
towards higher education uh a 2022
survey by morning consult found that 41
of genzirs said that they tend to trust
U.S colleges and universities the lowest
percentage of any generation it's a
significant shift from when Millennials
were in their shoes a decade ago a 2014
Pew research survey found that 63
percent of Millennials value to college
education or plan to get one and of
those who graduated 41 of that cohort
considered their schooling very useful
and that's compared to 45 percent of gen
xers and 47 of Boomers who felt the same
so we're finally starting to see this
this shift
um it took long enough
but it was inevitable
you know the university system as I've
been saying
since as long as I've had a platform is
a giant scam
and uh has been for a long time it's
arguably the greatest I mean you could
make an argument that the modern
University system is the greatest scam
in the history of the world I mean
certainly certainly among the most
expensive of of cons of scams of uh of
you know schemes in the history of the
world
we're talking billions and billions and
billions of dollars
and uh finally we're starting to see uh
that reality reflected
in the the attitude that people have
towards the university system and it's
an attitude of skepticism
you know the thing about this especially
when we talk about it and so often when
we talk about the university system
and somebody makes the kind of arguments
that I always make about uh you know
criticizing the system
it it almost always goes immediately to
this question of well is the education
useful can you use the education to go
out and get a job that's going to be a
high paying job and and that that pays
more than than the kind of job you could
get with without a college education and
what we find is that as a statistics
clearly show the answer to that is no I
mean in that sense the education is not
useful and uh in so many cases you're
going to have kids that spend a hundred
thousand dollars of money they don't
have and really it's a lot more than a
hundred thousand dollars when you factor
in uh interest and all the rest of it so
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
money they don't they don't have
um
to get on the promises that there's
going to be a return on investment and
then yeah they end up getting a job
either they get no job at the end of it
or they end up getting a job that pays
worse than if they just didn't go to
college at all
so
it's it's not useful in that sense which
is an important sense before getting our
dog rough greens he was so sad and lazy
well now he actually enjoys his squeaky
toys and playing Fetch with his frisbee
our pup stays are filled with laughter
exercise and endless fun naturopathic Dr
Dennis black the founder of rough grains
is focused on improving the health of
every dog in America little did I know
before I got rough grains dog food is
dead food everybody knows that nutrition
isn't Brown it's green well let rough
greens boost your dog's food back to
life Rock rains is a supplement that
contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog food you just sprinkle rough
grains on their food every day it's as
simple as that dog owners everywhere are
raving about rough greens it supports
healthy joints improves bad breath Boost
energy levels and so much more we are
what we eat and that goes for our dogs
too naturopathic Dr Dennis black is so
confident rough grains will improve your
dog's health he's offering my listeners
a free jump start trial bag so your dog
can try a free jumpstart trial bag can
be at your door in just a few business
days go to roughgreens.com Matt or call
844 rough 700 that's ruffgreens.com or
call 844 rough 700 today
Innovation refunds has been helping
small businesses that qualify to get a
business payroll tax refund through the
employee retention credit also known as
the ERC the ERC is a tax refund for
businesses that kept employees on
payroll for parts of 2020 and 2021 21 if
you own a business with more than five
employees you could have money waiting
to be claimed Innovation refunds
independent tax attorneys can help your
business's claims stay compliant with
IRS regulations and guidelines
Innovation refunds has hundreds of
five-star trust pilot in Google reviews
they're also accredited with the Better
Business Bureau Innovation refunds does
not provide tax or legal advice they
work with an independent network of tax
professionals and will share information
with them to evaluate and process your
claims go to innovationrefunds.com to
determine eligibility if you qualify you
could be on your way to receiving money
for your business there's no upfront
charge since they don't get paid unless
you get paid go to innovationrefunds.com
or dial 1-843 refunds that's
innovationrefunds.com or 1843 refunds
terms and conditions applied but it's
also true that ideally
you know we wouldn't really be talking
about
education in this way
um
ideally we would we would say that
education is worthwhile for its own sake
it's not so that you can use it
necessarily or at least that's not the
only that shouldn't be the only standard
that determines whether the education is
worthwhile is whether it can be used
and by use we mean can you can you learn
something and then take it out into the
world and monetize what you've learned
um
ideally it wouldn't it wouldn't be like
that we would say that well look even if
you can't monetize the education
directly uh still it's it's worthwhile
you know big education is supposed to it
makes you a more knowledgeable person it
makes you more makes you it's supposed
to make you a better person a more
interesting person a more well-rounded
person
education should be the kind of thing
that you pursue for its own sake
simply so that you can be an educated
person because it's good to be educated
it's better to be an educated person
than an uneducated person
ideally that's what we would that's how
we would treat education but you but
that's we can't
treat the modern college system that way
it's not something you can do just for
its own sake
partly that's because of the money
okay when it went a hundred thousand you
can't afford to do something it costs a
hundred thousand dollars for its own
sake
when it's that amount of money when that
when that's the kind of money we're
dealing with there has to be a return on
investment there just has to be
or normal people can't afford it and
that's what we're seeing
but then also too the education on its
own terms is worthless
even aside from the fact that you're not
going to be able to cash in and get a
high paying job
the education itself is worthless
because the University Systems are
ideologically captured completely they
have been for decades obviously that's
not breaking news and so the education
you're getting it's it's not even an
education at all I mean you're learning
things that aren't even true
so many kids they go to they go to
college and they come out more confused
about the world than they were when they
went in
so when I say it's one of the greatest
scams in the history well that's what
I'm talking about the these are the
levels that this scam exists on
you're spending all this money
with the promise that you'll be educated
and you'll be able to get a good job on
the other end of it and neither of those
promises are fulfilled
not only do you come out bankrupt broke
poor
not able to get any job at all
but you're more you're Dumber you're
more can defeat you're more confused
about the world you're in a worse
intellectual shape than you were when
you went
foreign
so if people are waking up to this fact
and finally realizing that um that we
need to extricate ourselves from this
system entirely then that's a very
that's a very very good sign
and this is once again where parents
come in because you know my my fear is
that we're seeing this shift uh away
from colleges but then you're going to
have the parents
who said well no this is this is a very
bad thing I mean I need my kid to go to
college my kid needs to go to college
you start you start trying to push your
kid into college don't do that
you know it's a very stupid thing to do
most people don't need college
especially this I mean this kind of
college system the universe system as it
currently exists nobody needs that
but really in any form
most people don't need that
most people don't need it in order to
get a job
you know they don't need it to you know
whatever they're going to end up doing
with their lives these are skills that
you have to just go out and Learn by
doing
that's that's the majority of jobs that
they require you know in order to
perform them well they require that you
have a skill set and in order to develop
that skill set you just have to go and
do it that's the only way to develop a
skill set we talked about this yesterday
um
so most people don't need college in
that sense and also most people don't
need college in order to learn
because it's not it's it's not like I
you know I'm even though I think that
most kids when they graduate high school
should not go to college that doesn't
mean that most kids in the graduate high
school should stop learning
now you should continue you should be
learning your entire life you should be
excited about learning your entire life
you should always be learning and
absorbing new information
but for most people there's no reason
why you have to learn After High School
in a formal sit-down classroom
environment
especially these days
you know where you could you can go on
the internet and the the the entire uh
you know culmination of Mankind's
knowledge is available at your
fingertips a lot of other things are
available too at your fingertips a lot
of things that you that you don't
necessarily want to to access but but if
you can sift through all of that uh you
can learn anything that you want just by
looking at that thanks for checking out
this video if you'd like to listen to my
full podcast on the go you can check out
the Matt wall show on Apple podcast
Spotify or wherever you get your podcast